times have been tough for the dozen clan
over the first two seasons of paramount
networks breakout Western drama
Yellowstone but they've apparently been
even tougher on series headliner Kevin
Costner from the sound of it Costner has
recently been having some second
thoughts about signing on to Yellowstone
the actor recently sat down with
indieWIRE to talk about the show's
recently wrapped second season and to
hear him tell it he's not enjoying
certain aspects of the modern cowboy
dramas production outside of the
rigorous shooting schedule kasnia's
biggest issue with the other stone is
apparently that he feels left in the
dark in regards characters past and
where Dustin is headed emotionally from
episode to episode
Costner told indieWIRE I'm not always
privy to aspects of the characters arc
know sometimes with Dustin's sons or
wife or whatever that's been really kept
in a creative ball that's the more
vulnerable way to go through life as an
actor given the rash of melodramatic
twists and turns out of accompany
seemingly every new episode of
Yellowstone over the show's first two
seasons it's easy to understand why
Costner might want a little more info
about this character after all it would
be difficult for any actor even one of
Costner's caliber to navigate all that
madness with any kind of emotional
honesty the Costner in particular
Yellowstone has proven an even bigger
challenge because he spend the bulk of
his decades-long career starring in
feature films which allows actors to
study the entirety of their
self-contained storylines and plots out
their characters arcs from start to
finish hard as it is to believe
Yellowstone is only the second
television series cos2 has ever started
with the first being the limited 3
episode 1 of The History Channel
miniseries Hatfields and McCoys in spite
of Yellowstone's breakout success
Costner still hasn't gotten used to the
vulnerability that comes with not
knowing what lies ahead for his
character during his interview Costner
bluntly stated it hasn't been an easy
adjustment for me I don't like it too
much well this may lead fans to believe
that Costner has designs on skedaddling
from Yellowstone a thankfully this isn't
the case
given the series impressive viewership
numbers Custer is enjoying as large an
audience as he has at any point in his
storied career Yellowstone is one of the
most watched series on cable television
and its ratings hit
all time high with the season 2 finale
though Costner may never quite adjust at
a rigorous shooting schedule and the
sometimes cloudy narrative of the series
he's still very much the star of a hit
show and is a crucial part of my fans
keep coming back from one week to the
next as it happens a show runners are
reportedly mapping out the show's fourth
win of episodes already and may have as
many as 7 full seasons of Yellowstone in
the works and there's little doubt that
they want Costner in the saddle for as
long as he can braid for proof of that
look no further than the actor's
astonishing $500,000 per episode salary
because nothing says we love you quite
like a good payday
seriously put this into perspective
yellowstone run for nine episodes in its
first season and was bumped up to ten
episodes for season two if the episode
order stays at ten and Yellowstone does
indeed run for a full seven seasons it
would finish his run with 69 episodes
which means Costner stands to net a
whopping thirty four point five million
dollars for his work on the show of
course given that the role of the
duplicitous Dutton is an exceedingly
complex one it's unlikely that Custer
will get bored with the gig any time
soon either and that can only be a good
thing however they do it though you can
be certain Yellowstone's creative team
will do everything in their power to
ensure that Kevin Costner is roping
ranching and scheming on the small
screen for the foreseeable future the
series highly anticipated third season
is expected to premiere on paramount
Network in the summer of 2020 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos by your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]